girl bring long shot long rebound off
the yield Lakers are running wing and I
mean and he attacked with a purpose
great job of finishing by Caruso and
he's going to the line for a possible
three-point play as a Chuck
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
they've led the entire way largest lead
20 right now 16 as we open the fourth
all Caruso throws it down during the
timeout and as they continue Autism
Awareness playing defense easy steal for
his last dunk as he score now there's
some pressure on the funders did you see
turns the corner Steven Adams rotates
slowly and swipes and Caruso says yes I
have hops oh look at that focus
top team in the West magic number for
Golden State is three Rondo three
[Applause]
Oh came off the weak side and puts in
the gym he is one of seven that's just a
moment he gave everybody a jolt take a
break then take you to the American
Express halftime report nobody's sitting
because of a blowout here's DRAM
[Applause]
in a defensive play look at that puts
his hand out knocks down the flat angle
runs it down and Dennis hammers one
James got it out to caldwell-pope alex
caruso is more athletic than you think
and he worked hard on his body goes to
the rim with authority and leaves no
doubt mr. Cleveland might have been
better served to step to the left
[Applause]
another look at the died by Caruso and
the finishes Jim Johnston gets out of
the way I don't want a piece of that we
do I'm not on any poster tonight
as basket the Lakers hair was a nice
drive by Caruso he just hampers one of
his specialties but it's not enough as
the Sun still lead by two he was going
to Rondo on that play did a great job of
looking off to defender but all of a
sudden Caruso is available open path for
the rim the delivery by Davis and the
Finnish vodka Russo and just like that
the Lakers go back up by tears
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this shot by Danny Green Dwight thinks
he's got it off has a rebound all of a
sudden here comes Caruso nobody put a
body on him and he put a highlight play
up into the stands here
[Applause]
look at the Lakers go Lakers go up 88-79
just in the NBA in free-throw percentage
last heading in the second quarter make
yourself important in other ways watch
him step straight in see nobody's boxing
out
Anderson just step straight to the
free-throw line and Caruso says look I
can out-jump you it does what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content